Музыка Субтитры создавал DimaTorzok Ganz herzlich willkommen zu dieser exklusiven Folge, das Podcast UFO. Heute bei uns natürlich Esteban Tizioso. Schön, auch schön, dass Sie da sind, herzlich willkommen. Vielen Dank, danke für die Einladung und mit dabei ist auch Florian David-Bascal Will. Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Wir haben gerade gehört eine Interpretation von Ruth und Rebecca, vielen, vielen Dank dafür. Und deswegen haben wir eine kleine Diskussionsrunde eröffnet, um über dieses Werk ein wenig zu sprechen. Naja, man hat deutlich gemerkt, dass hier mit dem Prinzip der Frage und der Antwort gespielt wurde, ähnlich wie der Podcast, das ja auch dann aufgreift, dann im weitesten Sinne. Die Dialogstruktur. Die Dialogstruktur wurde aufgegriffen im Intro bereits mit dem vorhandenen Werk, ein von Michael Giacchino gekomponiertes Werk. Ursprünglich wurde dieses Werk komponiert für eine Achterbahn namens Space Mountain. Einen Vergnügungspark namens Space Mountain. Ja, also aus der Populärwelt stammt dieses Stück. Ganz was Ulkiges wurde da versucht, ein Abenteuer in einer klassischen Dreierarchistruktur mit diesem, Kennt man ja, wenn dann die Achterbahn zunächst hochrollt, hochgetragen wird, auf den Stahlträgern braust, da hat man zunächst am Anfang diese Antizipation, ehe man dann in diesen ekstatischen Pfad kommt. Ja, richtig. Aus dem man auch nicht mehr rauskommt. Naher in der Programmmusik hier schon von Ruth und Rebecca. Und ich habe auch gemerkt, ich weiss nicht, welche der beiden hier die Violine gespielt hat,
sie hat eifrig mit diesem langen Holzstock auf dem Instrument hin und her gerieben quasi.
Gerieben bis Töne heraus, ja, ich würde sagen, zu explodieren droht.
Richtig, sie hat dem Instrument die Töne entlockt quasi mit diesem Stecken.
Das kann man so sagen, ja. Und also ich fand das sehr, sehr ansprechend, ganz toll. Vielen, vielen Dank an Ruth und Rebecca und den Tonmeister Hendrik Weiskopf, Christoph Henrik Weiskopf, Christoph Schwarzkopf, wir sind uns nicht. Konrad Weiskopf, also der hier auch wirklich den Ton gemischt hat. Tonmeister Konrad Weisskopf, vielen Dank an diese Interpretation von Michael Giacchinos Space Mountain Satz 1. Wir verabschieden uns und entlassen euch in den Abend. Macht's gut, weiterhin viel Spaß und Freude. Hier an dieser Stelle übernehme jetzt Flo und den Willen und Germanitze vom Podcast UFO, viel Spaß. Vom Erfolgspodcast, vom populären Podcast UFO, mittlerweile in vielen Ländern Afrikas verboten, aber hier auf dem Sender läuft die Sendung. Man kann ja nichts tun für sein Nachprogramm. Gut, dann ab jetzt viel Spaß mit Das Podcast UFO. Herzlich willkommen, ich war letztes bei Aldi und kennst du es, wenn du die vier Muffins in der Plastikpackung hast? Oh mein Gott. Unterdienst, wer will denn vier Muffins? Ich will mindestens fünf Stimmel. Ich bin hin, ich bin zurück, ich bin nach oben, ich bin nach unten hingeschlagen, Boosted Board, Eis, Kratze, Eis, Kratze. Steine These, steine These, Rassismus, latente
Fremdfändigkeit. Nein, wir können
ja sozial, haben wir ja gar nichts auf dem
Kasten. Entschuldigung
für letzte Folge, Entschuldigung
für letzte Folge. Aber Podcast
preist dann doch bitte abstimmen, mir
kommt die Werbung. Ciao!
Ach ja, schön, dass du da bist.
Stefan ist freundlich. Ich freue mich auch, dass du da bist.
Hier mal wieder zu zweit im Trautenheim, nicht
vor Publikum. Genau, nicht falsch verstehen, diese Folge
ist nicht live. Also das ist jetzt alles
Vielen Dank. Ach ja, schön, dass du da bist. Ich freue mich auch, dass du da bist. Hier mal wieder zu zweit im Trautenheim, nicht vor Publikum. Genau, nicht falsch verstehen, diese Folge ist nicht live. Also das ist jetzt alles vorher schon aufgenommen. Nicht, dass jetzt guckt, wo kommen diese Stimmen her, was passiert hier gerade, wo bin ich? Nein, nein, nein, das haben wir schon im Vorhinein aufgenommen. Jetzt kommt es zu euch über das Internet. Über den Äther, sagt man ja manchmal. Ja. Aber dass es das Wort überhaupt noch geben darf, ist ja auch weird, ne? Das ist eigentlich ein Frecher. Eigentlich ein Quatsch. Eigentlich ein großer Fauxpas. Ich habe damals im Lateinunterricht, als es hieß Äther, die antike Welt hat sich vorgestellt, dass es einen Äther gibt, in dem alles ist irgendwie. Da dachte man sich zunächst, wenn ihr was cooles findet, was für alles die Erklärung ist, warum nennt ihr es dann Äther? Ich dachte mir, Äther, okay, das ist auch ein Gegenstand aus Pokémon und hab dann gefragt, was ist überhaupt Äther? Und da wurde ich schon angeschaut auch von der Klasse. Da war man schon im Alter, wo herablassend die normale Art war, Gleichgesinnten gegenüberzutreten. Und schäme ich mich bis heute, dass ich diese Frage gestellt habe. Was war die dümmste Frage, die du je gestellt hast? Innerhalb oder außerhalb der Schule, wo du dir wirklich im Nachhinein denkst, das sollte ich eigentlich wissen? Die dümmste Frage, die ich jemals gestellt habe, war hier auch im Podcast, glaube ich. Na klar. Weil ich dachte, dass ... Ich habe Waffen, Schusswaffen immer nicht verstanden. Und dachte, dass hinten der Revolver, da kommt ja so eine Klappe raus. Der Hahn, ja. Ich dachte, dass das die Kugel anstößt. Okay. Und wenn man so einen richtigen Schwung gibt und dann das Geschoss rauskommt. Und das wird schon, weil man ja auch dann doch beeindruckt war, damals in der Schule, als man sich diese Blasrohr gebaut hat und da so ein Spucke-Kügelchen drin hatte. Man war ja schon erstaunt, wie viel so ein Luftschub ja dann auch an Kraft und Schupe wirkt, vom Mund, und deswegen dachte ich ja, das wird ja wohl reichen, wenn da so ein Metallding hinten gegen die Kugel anschubst und dann hast du halt ein bisschen Reibung, aber in der Fall ist das sehr schnell. Das war vielleicht das Dümmste, was ich jemals gesagt habe. Absolut. Ich glaube, die dümmste Überzeugung, die ich hier hatte, habe ich wahrscheinlich schon mal erzählt, aber ich dachte, dass in einer Spülmaschine, wenn die spült, also Geschirr spült, dass die randvoll mit Wasser läuft. Dass das die Art ist, wie die Geschirr spült. Also die läuft randvoll mit Wasser und dann halt wird es so gestrudelt oder irgendwie sowas und dann wird es wieder abgelaufen. Deswegen hatte ich auch immer panische Angst davor die während dem waschgang aufzumachen weil ich dachte da brechen jetzt gleich 200 liter aber dann gab es für dich ja wahrscheinlich diesen tollen moment mal irgendwann wo jemand auf die idee gekommen ist eine gopro da rein zu machen genau wo alle anderen die sich immer ausgelacht haben weil die da weil die genau gedachten gewusst durchschaut zu haben wie es funktioniert nämlich mit propellern und einfach sp Chemie. Nein, da kommt so ein weirder Sarlacc-Wurm, kommt raus und es sieht so otherworldly aus, wie er dann so rum, als würde es fast leben, kommt dann raus und trifft mal hier was, es hat auch kein System und jemand wird da so reingesogen, wie so ein Arm, der dann seine Beute hat, so eine Marde, die dann so, nochmal kurz schreit und dann sich wieder zurückzieht, weil die Helden da mit dem Raumschiff rausgeflogen sind. Aber das hätte mir auch niemand geglaubt, wenn ich gesagt hätte, da kommt irgendwie so ein weirder Wurm raus und spritzt überall Wasser. Ja, weil du immer dachtest, das ist im Podcast dann auch so, ja, ich dachte, und ich dachte immer, wie ein weirder Wurm, und ich dachte, nee, es sind da oben diese Dinger und Wasserspritzer und so ist ausgelacht und irgendwann,i der Wurm. Aber absolut, apropos Salakwurm, hast du es gecheckt, was diese Woche rauskam über Star Wars? Nee. Man muss ja dazu sagen, du bist ja kein Star Wars Fan mehr. Das stimmt nicht, aber... Du hast zu mir gesagt, nach Episode 9, hast du gesagt, ich bin jetzt kein Star Wars Fan mehr. Habe ich glaube ich nicht, so gesagt. Ich habe glaube ich auch meinen Blick, es fällt mir schwer, mich noch so doll für Star Wars zu begeistern, wie ich es mal geschafft habe. Und deswegen, es ist einfach, es tut so ein bisschen weh, wie das Franchise hinten raus so behandelt wurde, obwohl ich ein großer Fan von Episode acht war, also von der Art, wie der Film gemacht wurde und allem, was man darüber hört. Und ich mag den Film auch sehr gern. Trotzdem, ja, hinten raus haben mich die Filme dann als Star Wars Filme nicht mehr gepackt. Und das hat mich dann so ein bisschen abgeschreckt. Da hast du auch gar nicht mitbekommen, was diese Woche rausgekommen ist. Ich finde, das ist ja eigentlich immer das Spannendste, wenn teilweise noch Sachen erklärt werden, nachdem der Film draußen ist. So dieses klassische Dumbledower-Schwul-Ding, wo halt man irgendwie acht Filme macht und man sagt,
du hattest acht Filme Zeit, das zu erklären.
Also es hat mehr als genug Platz.
Ich mut, da waren im Buch teilweise noch hundert Seiten leer in der Mitte, die hättest du ja
füllen können, da war ja Platz.
Hättest du einfach grossschwul hinschreiben können.
Ja genau, einfach stockschwul
schon immer.
Kannst du ja einfach reinschreiben, hat sie nicht gemacht,
sondern nachgereicht. Und das sind ja immer die besten Sachen,
die nachgereicht werden. Und jetzt wurde nachgereicht, dass Palpatine anscheinend ein Klon war. Ja. Aber ganz gerafft habe ich es nicht, weil der Snoke ein Klon war, wurde ja enthüllt in Episode 9. Aber jetzt war, und das fanden alle scheiße und dann haben sie gesagt, ja gut, wenn alle das scheiße fanden, dann machen wir Palpatine auch noch zu dem Klon. Ich habe es gar nicht gerafft, aber erschreckenderweise war es mir auch völlig egal. Nee, hab ich tatsächlich leider doch gelesen, hab ich sofort wieder vergessen, aber mir ist gerade eingefallen, dass das unser lieber Antennal-Darren-Kollege Thilo Grimm auch gepostet hat. Ja, das sind so Sachen, also, ändert ja nix an gar nichts, an einem Film, der eh nichts ändert oder geleistet oder kreativ schafft. Es hat null kreative Fallhöhe, es hat einfach hingerotzt, um irgendwelche Leute zu pleasen. Ich weiß gar nicht, für wen die das dann machen und so. Und auch DJ Abrams hat sich ja so mega distanziert dann auch am Ende des Tages und so. Und es gibt ja auch mehr als eindeutige Interviews über den Film. Ich hoffe, dass Rowling jetzt nachzieht und sowas nachsagt wie, ja, übrigens Neville war auch ein Klon die ganze Zeit. Ja, Neville war ein Klon und Dumbledore war ein schwuler Klon. Von dem sehr heterosexuellen Ursprungs-Dumbledore. Genau, ja, aber einfach, wenn man sagt, wir haben einen Klon, wir haben auch, wir haben zwei Klone. Wir haben zwei, Crab Goyle, beide Klone. Und dann so Tolkien sagt dann, die Erben von Tolkien. Ganz kurz, Gimli war na...
Sowas von geklont, da war nichts echt.
Zwillingsklon. Ja, der wurde in der Hälfte
von die zwei Türme ausgetauscht,
durch seinen Zwillingsbruder, hat niemand
gemerkt. Jetzt erst kam's raus.
Und dann aber die von How to Train
a Dragon kommen dann um die Ecke
und alle Kinder, what?
Oder die How to Sell Drugs Online
Fast kommt raus und sagt Moritz, sowas von Klon, aber von der ersten Sekunde an. Einfach im Nachhinein kannst du noch Sachen dazu nicht. Man kann sehr viel Bullshit behaupten, hat dann auch gar keine Relevanz mehr. Ja. Oder? Also das finde ich immer so, nachträglich ist, was nachzureichen, finde ich immer ganz, ganz, ganz schwierig. Ja, wie auch, glaube ich, bei Roseanne oder so in der letzten Staffel war es da nochmal so, dass das alles gar nicht stattgefunden hat, sondern sich irgendwie so ein autistisches Kind nur ausgedacht hat. Die komplette letzte Staffel ist nicht passiert, in Anführungszeichen, sondern war nur eine Fantasie. Und das ist auch so, ja, so what, wir haben es ja gesehen. Also es ist so ganz merkwürdig, was da jetzt der Effekt sein soll. Schwierig. Ich habe gerade Labello aufgetragen, weil es ist wieder this time of the year. Eigentlich habe ich nur ... Aber es fühlt sich schlecht an. Nee, es fühlt sich sehr angenehm an sogar. Es ist auch so, da habe ich mich auch über mich selber geärgert, aber ich habe den Labello for Men gekauft, wo ich auch dachte, warum machst du das denn jetzt, warum unterstützt du diese Genderscheisse? So, aber dann habe ich die halt gekauft, weil da stand dann sehr gut für Männerlippen. Da dachte ich mir, ja, vielleicht sind Männerlippen ja anders als Frauenlippen und brauchen was anderes und dann nehme ich das jetzt. Ja, fair Bullshit wahrscheinlich. Ich hätte einfach den Standardlabello nehmen können oder den mit mehr Feuchtigkeit. Aber der für Männer war dann 50 Cent billiger oder wie? Nee, nee, ich habe einfach dann gedacht, ja, vielleicht ist das das, was ich brauche. Und wenn Leute einen angucken, dumme Leute in der Öffentlichkeit angucken, kann man sagen, nee, ist vom Mann. Aber auf der anderen Seite, das ist ganz doof. Da habe ich mich immer sehr geärgert, braucht man nicht wieder schreiben jetzt. Weiss ich schon selber, dass man das vielleicht nicht unterstützen sollte. Aber den habe ich jetzt drauf gemacht und es fühlt sich, naja, der glänzt nicht so. Es fühlt sich zu männlich an. Es fühlt sich zu männlich an. Zu viel Testosteron. Nee, so männlich bin ich nicht, wie der Lebello ist. Pass auf, was du jetzt sagst, nicht dass deine Lippen... Naja, so Chauvi, komm jetzt raus, so Chauvinismus-Scheiss. Nee, ehrlich gesagt, mag ich das ganz gerne, weil so einen wohligen Film auf meinen Lippen breitet. Ich mag das irgendwie gar nicht auf den Lippen, ich will nichts auf den Lippen haben. Es schränkt mich irgendwie ein. Ich habe dann das Gefühl, es ist so, ich tue das auch mal sofort weg. Manchmal so, wenn man Make-up bekommt oder so für eine Film oder Serie oder sowas, dann machen die oft Make-up und manche Make-up-Artists machen dann auch oft einfach so Labello drauf oder irgendwas auf die Lippen, ungefragt. Einfach dann drauf, manchmal wird gefragt, willst du was? Und dann machst du so und dst dann den Kopf so weg, wie man das, oh, unverfaltige Schauspieler allühen.
Ich boxe dann mit Händen und Füssen einfach die weg. Und wirklich das Erste, was ich mache, wenn ich dann den Trailer verlasse oder so, ich wische mir das sofort weg, weil ich kann dieses Gefühl nicht haben, irgendwas auf den Lippen zu haben. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, also ich glaube, ich wäre da auch, wenn ich mich selber schminken würde oder so, ich würde das gar nicht ertragen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es dann auch einfach Gewöhnungssache, auch so Kajale oder so finde ich alles, ich weiß nicht, ich will nichts im Gesicht haben. Irgendwie habe ich da keinen Bock. Du hast auch ein ganz großes Problem mit Augen, muss man auch sagen. Und so, wohingegen, das ist das Schlimmste, wenn man es im Auge hat oder so, so fettiges Auge. Vor allem, was ich gar nicht verstehe, ist dieser Bereich Innenauge, also so zwischen Nase und Auge, so die Tränensäcke und so. Das ist für mich ein Mysterium, was da überhaupt los ist, weil manchmal hat man dann da irgendwie einen Krümel und dann denke ich mir so, was passiert, wenn der da jetzt reingeht, was kommt da, also da sind dann so die Tränensäcke drin, Sack, wo, was, wo soll das sein, keine Ahnung, ich könnte es googeln, aber ich will das gar nicht wissen. Tränensäcke sind, nee, Tränensäcke ist ja der Ausdruck für Augenringe, oder nicht auch? Nee, Tränensäcke sind Menschen, die viel weinen. Tränen, das ist ein Tränensack. Bedusseliger Tränensack. Ich weiß wirklich nicht, aber da habe ich wirklich Angst. Ich mag das nicht, die Vorstellung, dass irgendwas da reingeht. Meine Tränensäcke sieht man, wenn ich lache. Wie du siehst, siehst du jetzt meine Tränensäcke.
Das ist unter dem Auge direkt. Unter dem Auge oder was? Genau, und da drunter kommen dann die Augenringe, das sind dann an. Unterauge, kannst du sagen, ja. Unterauge ist Tränensack und dann da drin, ja da drin hast du dann halt diese, da wird es manchmal blau, wenn du blutblau unterlaufen, wenn du nicht so gut schläfst und so. Ja, da ist halt komische Territorien. Da wird dann auch so ein, das sind so sensible Gefilde, da will man auch nicht unbedingt drin vor oben reindringen. Nee, genau. Genau, ich finde, damit kommt man mit klar. Aber ich finde es super, du hast trockene Lippen und du hast eine Lösung, Labelle. Wobei jetzt dachte ich erst so geil, dass du was hast, was dafür einfach ist, aber es wird ja auch nicht besser. Ich mache jetzt nur drei Tage drauf, ich sehe so, dass meine Lippen jetzt dadurch besser werden. Ich muss mich nur erinnern, als wir das erste Mal in New York waren und du irgendwie eine ganz merkwürdige Lippenallergie oder irgendwas hattest, dass deine Lippen immer mit gutem Farbton dunkler waren Und du einfach ausgesehen hast, als würdest du Lippenstift tragen, aber einen, der auch nicht gut passt in dein Gesicht. Nee, rot. Also fast knallrot. Kirschrot. Aber es sah sehr sinnlich aus auf eine Art. Nee, sinnliche, tolle Lippen. Aber auf der anderen Seite kam das auch durch trockene Lippen. Und das habe ich jetzt auch so ein bisschen. Und die sind auch so ein bisschen bisschen dunkler und dann sieht es immer so aus, wenn ich eine Labelle benutze, da habe ich mir einfach roten Lippenstifter drauf machen, weil die danach so.
Ich fahre mit meinen Freunden im Sommer immer zum Campen eine Woche und da fahre man mit dem Fahrrad hin und bei irgendeinem Jahr ist mal einer meiner Freunde verunglückt und der ist irgendwie einfach, weil er ein Vollidiot ist, ist einfach in ein parkendes Auto reingefahren und ist anscheinend so gestürzt, dass man könnte seinen Sturz am besten so beschreiben, dass er dieses Auto geküsst hat im Flug. Also er ist übers Fahrrad geflogen und ist dann mit den Lippen gegen das Auto geschlagen. Knautschzone, Krutschzone. Abgeknut, ja, geknutzone, richtig. Und dadurch sind seine Lippen richtig hart angeschwollen, auf die doppelte Größe. Wodurch er natürlich die gesamte Woche Ziel unserer hämischen pubertären Witze war, weil er einfach aussah, als hätte er sich die Lippen aufgespritzt. Aber ich dachte immer so, was ist denn, wenn das jemand... Vor allem auch ganz geil, wie so ein Camping-Odau unter Jungs, wo man mal halt man mal so eine Woche mal alleine ist und man hat halt einer total geile Lippen.
Es war aber das beste Timing. Wenn du eine Woche, also als 15-Jähriger, wenn du eine Woche scheisse aussehen willst, dann wo du eine Woche mit deinen Freunden weg bist von allen anderen, wo du nicht in die Schule musst, wo das alles nicht stattfindet. Und ich dachte nur so, vielleicht für Leute, die sich die Lippen aufspritzen lassen wollen, aber nicht viel Geld haben, einfach mal gegen die Wand rennen. Gegen Parken das Autofahren. Gegen Parken das Autofahren. Es funktioniert für eine Woche. Man muss es halt dann jede Woche machen. Aber du musst ja auch nachspritzen jede Woche, so nach dem Motto. Wirklich? Ja, häufig. Ne, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, es ist billiger letzten Endes als eine OP. Kann gut sein. Also überlegt euch das mal. Probiert es mal aus. Ich finde, das Wort Knautsch ist mir das schönste Wort der deutschen Sprache. Knautsch ist wirklich gut. Aber du benutzt es bei Knautschzone. Ja. Aber das Knautscht. Aber man kann auch Verknautscht ein bisschen sein, oder? Nee, was guckst du denn so? Verknatscht. Ne, zerknatscht? Zerknatscht. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Knautsch und Knatsch? Ja, und Knutsch. Ja, Knutsch ist klar, aber Knutsch gibt es gar nicht. Also bei U hat man gesagt, nee, und Knitsch auch nicht. Es gibt A, U und A, U. Knatsch, Knutsch und Knautsch. Ja. Aber ist Zerknautscht und Zerknautscht was anderes? Ja. Was ist der Unterschied? Zerknautscht ist, glaube ich, Zieharmonika-mässig gedacht. Ja, ja. Das ist eingeknautscht. Wenn so eine Dampffalze über einen drüber fährt und man dann erst ist man ganz platt auf der Strasse und dann so blablabla und dann ist man so ein bisschen zerknautscht. Das hat man so wie so eine Ziehharmonika. Ja, aber sehr wichtig beim Auto, so überlebenswichtig, aber etwas überlebenswichtiges sollte man nicht Knautschzone nennen, meiner Meinung nach, aber wer bin ich, das ist zu judgen. Auf der anderen Seite kenne ich es auch nur in der Beziehung mit Zone, Knautschzone, das kennt man als Wort, aber sonst bin ich mit dem Begriff Knautschen noch nicht sehr vertraut. Es ist halt nah an Autsch dran, das ist halt vielleicht ein Problem. Autschi, Autsch, Aua. Ich habe jetzt einen Schweizer Kollegen, der immer alles verniedlicht, Hemdchen, das ist einfach, aber es ist, es macht einen zum besseren Menschen. Ja. Also das Gefühl ist ein anderes, du nimmst die Welt lockerer wahr, weil ich gewinne mir das auch neuerdings immer an, weil wir halt auch sehr viel Zeit ineinander bringen, und dann fängst du halt immer an, alles zu verniedlichen. Hemdchen, Häuschen, Häuschen, alles ist so süss, alles ist niedlich und klein. Aber verniedlicht man in der Schweiz nicht mit einem I, so Häusli? Häusli, ja, aber er überträgt das natürlich in sein Hochdeutsch. Ach, er hat sich erst integriert, sozusagen. Er glaubt ja auch immer, dass er fließend Hochdeutsch spricht, und das ist eigentlich nur ein R. Weil in der Schweiz lernt man ja Hochdeutsch auch, aber die haben eine andere Vorstellung von, das machen die Deutschen da oben, so sagen die das. Und dann kommt er hier immer, stößt er immer an seine Grenzen und merkt dann, ah okay, so sprechen wir auch nicht. Er hat sich nur so ein wie, wenn du mit deinem Schulenglisch irgendwo hinläufst, sagen die ja auch, ja, nee, sagen die Engländer ja auch, so sprechen wir ja nicht. Und so ist es bei denen ein bisschen auch, ist sehr lustig und er überträgt das alles mit Chen und es ist schon einfach, es macht was mit dir. Wir haben auch lange darüber Sprache gesprochen und dass eine Sprache so ein bisschen so eine Art Betriebssystem ja auch für den Kopf ist. Ich habe das Gefühl, du kannst mit einer Sprache so ein bisschen auch ein besseres Gefühl geben. Ich glaube, wenn du wirklich alles verniedlichst, dann hilft das auch für den Weltfluss. Ich nehme die Welt mittlerweile lockerer wahr, ist alles ja nie viel klein. Die Schweizer ja ein legendär friedliches Volk oder zumindest die halten sich raus. Da kommen dann die Wehrmachtli und so und die, ach ja, da machen wir nicht mit. Macht mal. Ne, macht mal, guckt mal, schaut mal, was passiert. Und dann drohen sie dann immer damit, den Gotthard zu sprengen. Das ist immer auch geil, alles ist süss und niedlich, aber wenn dann mal was kommt, dann sprengen wir den Gotthard. Ja genau, die nutzen die beiden Extreme der Sprache, so ganz süss, aber auch ganz hart. Ja, so ein Berg, wo die dann meinen, dann ist vorbei. Ich glaube auch niemand interessiert sich dann auch wirklich für den Gotthard und man fliegt einfach drüber. Aber das sind wohl wichtige Tunnel, gehen durch den Gotthard und dann wird der Gotthard gesprengt. Ja, du Arsch. Egal wo auf der Welt was passiert, wenn Trump nochmal gewählt wird, dann sprengen wir unseren Gotthard. Ja genau, jetzt ist ja auch Corona in Norditalien und so und die Schweiz sagt, vielleicht sprengen wir jetzt den Gotthard, weil das kommt uns hier zu nah. Und dann wird der Gotthard gespennt. Wir müssen ja ganz weit husten, so ganz Langstrecken husten, also über die ganze Gebirgskette drüber. Kann auch funktionieren. Spürst du Hysterie? Hysterie, ja. Spürst du Historie? Ja, eine ganze Menge. Ich versuche mich wieder so ein bisschen weiterzubilden, geschichtlich, aber ich stosse an meine Grenzen. Spürst du denn Hysterie? Nein, Hysterie spüre ich nicht, aber ich bin guter Dinge auf jeden Fall. Du bist guter Dinge? Ich bin immer noch guter Dinge. Ich auch. Ich habe mir jetzt so ein bisschen so eine eigene Quarantäne verschrieben und verlasse die Wohnung nicht mehr. Das hast du vorher auch. Ja, man fühlt sich besser. Du hast eine gute, du hast eine bessere Ausrede. Du bist besser darin. Genau, man fühlt sich besser und dann, ich glaube irgendwie so, wenn ich der einzige überlebende Mensch dann in 20 Jahren bin, also wie haben sie es geschafft zu überleben? Ja, ich war halt einfach zu Hause viel und ich habe halt ein bisschen ein paar Kübel Senf geholt und bin halt dann eher so zu Hause unterwegs. Kann man auch überleben, nur Senf zu essen? Ich glaube, es fehlt Salz. Ich glaube, du brauchst Salz, sonst stirbt man irgendwann, wenn man keinen Salz hat. Deswegen, immer wenn was passiert, das Erste, was man macht, Badewanne voller Salz. Wenn ihr merkt, oh, oh, jetzt geht's los, ganz viel Salz holen, Badewanne randvoll mit Salz, dass man auf jeden Fall erstmal langfristig seinen Salzbedarf gedeckt hat.
Lieber Salz als Wasser?
Ja, ja, ja. Wasser bringt dir gar nichts, wenn du kein Salz hast. Und dann kannst du dir...
Was?
Du brauchst gar nicht anfangen, wenn du kein Salz hast. Wenn du dann in deiner Turmbunger steigst und du guckst dir, haben wir Salz? Nee, ja, dann können wir es auch lassen, dann können wir auch wieder rausgehen. So, weil ohne Salz haben wir keine Chance. Ganz, ganz wichtig, Badewanne randvoll mit Salz. Wer, wo, hattest du das gelesen? Nee, nee, das ist so ein Mickey-Maus-Magazin oder so. Das ist ganz wichtig. Wobei, es sagt Bear Grylls dann auch ab und zu, dass das Beste ist, wenn du in der Wildnis überleben willst, eigentlich erst mal Pfeffer und Salz mitnehmen. Schmeckt alles geil. Du kannst alles genießbar machen mit Pfeffer und Salz. Ja, du brätst dir so eine Schlange oder so und wir wissen ja alle Schlangenfleisch ein bisschen ekelig, ja. Ein bisschen ekelhaft, einfach schön Pfeffer, Salz, ein bisschen Dill, ein bisschen Parflet. Pfeffer und Salz. Ah, jetzt rieche ich Hunger auf Schlange. Ja, lang nicht mehr gegessen. G zu selten. Gönnt man sich viel zu selten, es gibt so einen Laden auf der Fenloher Strasse. Man geht zu selten hin. Und man kriegt die dann in so einer Eiswaffel und dann wird die so aufgeschlängelt, so wie so ein Soft-Eis, so auf der Eiswaffel und dann kann man die auch ablecken. Und dann hast du eine richtig schöne Schlange. Oder halt Schlange am Stock, da wird dann in die Schlange so ein ganz langer Stock eingeführt und du kannst dir dann halt so halten, also in ihrer Länge und dann so abknabbern.
Und so abziehen.
So schaschlig mässig kannst du dir dann direkt abknabbern.
Eigentlich geil.
Und die Haut ist natürlich das Beste.
Na, eben.
Ja, eigentlich.
Perfekt.
Sagt sich an, weil beim Hühnchen ist die Haut das Beste und Schlange hat primär Haut.
Das verstehe ich nicht, warum ein Huhn, ein Huhn wird ja möglichst kugelig gezüchtet.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich dumm, weil eine Kugel hat ja die niedrigste Oberfläche. Du willst ja, dass die in irgendeiner lange Schlange sich züchten, damit man ganz viel Haut hat. Oder sind dafür die Flügel da, dass man noch ein bisschen mehr Oberfläche dazukriegt? Weiß ich nicht. Das ist aber eine spannende These, dass eine Kugel am wenigsten Oberfläche hat. Ich glaube schon, oder?
Nee, das halte ich für ganz gross. Da hältst du dich raus. Du willst nach den Hot Takes der letzten Woche nicht noch einen Fehler machen. Was war denn das schon wieder los? Kam schon wieder ein Shitstorm? Klar, natürlich. Nein, alles gut. Mittlerweile bin ich vorsichtig geworden. Man wird dressiert. Brauchst du nicht. Brauchst du nicht. Muss ich auch mal sagen, die neue Staffel Curb the Basics und ehrlich gesagt finde ich das ganz schwierig, weil es ein alter, weisser Mann ist, der keinen wirklich tollen Zugang zu der MeToo-Debatte gefunden hat und was mich sehr traurig gestimmt hat und so. Er kriegt dann hier und da gefühlt, aber er will nicht das zu entscheiden, aber er kriegt hier und da dann wieder die Kurve und dann ist es wieder Kirby, wir das kennen, aber hier und da echt schwierig und will man auch teilweise dann gar nicht gucken. Da waren auch so ein paar Szenen dabei, wo man einfach skippen will und so. Und da sind ja die schlimmsten Leute und so war er auch dann ab und zu dieses, die heutzutage sagen, ja das kann man ja jetzt, heutzutage kann man ja nicht mehr alles sagen, das sind eigentlich die schlimmsten, da will man ja nicht in diese Richtung, will man ja gar nicht abdriften. Ich finde es immer gefährlich, das ist das neue, kein Nazi aber, ich bin kein Nazi aber, für mich ist immer Leute, die sagen, heutzutage kann man ja nicht mehr über alles Witze machen. Da sollten wir immer die Alarmglocken angehen, weil man kann ja immer noch über alles Witze machen. Ich bin noch nicht ganz durch mit der Staffel, ich habe die ersten paar Folgen mir geholt, aber die Staffel davor habe ich auch noch nachgeholt, die fand ich fantastisch. Ich fand die wirklich fantastisch.
Riecht fantastisch. Also gerade so, es ist ja so ein bisschen der Moment, wenn deine Lieblingsstaffel irgendwie in die sechste, siebte, achte Staffel geht und man sich denkt, wann wird es schlecht, wann wird es schlecht, aber da auf jeden Fall zumindest die siebte.
Man hofft aber auch, dass es schlecht wird, weil es so viel anderes Angebot gibt und man denkt die ganze Zeit,, jetzt hole ich schon wieder Curb. Und dann war ich fast froh, dass es schlecht wird, weil dann kann man sich ja wieder was anderes gucken. Man neigt ja auch dann dazu, bei dem zu bleiben. Man will den Abstieg, den Absprung schaffen. Man will den Absprung einfach irgendwann schaffen. Man muss auch so eine Beziehung mal beenden und sagen, das war's. Ich habe dich immer weggesnackt während dem Essen und jetzt sind wir einfach zu Ende. Jetzt reicht es einfach mal auch dann. Jetzt ist es auch mal gut. Ich kann Handwerker nicht mehr sehen, ich habe sehr viel, jetzt umgezogen bin ich, jetzt geht mein Internet nicht mehr. An beiden Standorten geht es jetzt nicht mehr. Leider Gott ist es so dumm gelaufen wegen Timing und so und Kündigungsfrist, dass ich jetzt noch leider Gottes zwei Wohnungen gerade unterhalten muss, was echt bescheuert ist. Und da jetzt habe ich, weil in der einen neuen Wohnung sollte Internet bereitgestellt werden, wo erstmal war der Telekom ein riesen Arschloch, der hat mich offen beleidigt, muss man sagen. Weil er dich kannte oder so? Nee, weil er, weil ich mein Klingelschild noch nicht beschriftet habe. Ah, gut. Gut, Anfängerfehler. Und dann ging das Internet auch nicht, dann war er komplett, ist er sauer abgedüst dann wieder. Und jetzt habe ich trotzdem mit meiner alten, Telekom sich entschlossen, in meinem alten, in meinem alten Wohl, mein Internet aber auch zu kappen, jetzt habe ich nirgendwo mehr Internet und es ist alles verloren. Und dann kriegt man einfach schlechte Laune. Ja, total. Und dann ist es auch, man merkt plötzlich, wie alleine man plötzlich ist, wenn man kein Internet mehr hat. Ja, und was für ein Mensch man auch ist. Was bin ich denn für ein Mensch? Ausserhalb des Internets. Was sind wir, wir definieren es ja auch durch den Podcast, durch die Serie, so durch, du definierst dich durch den Streaming, die Rocket Beans.
Was bist du ohne das Internet, mal ganz im Ernst? Du, ich habe in Hamburg in der Wohnung ab und zu Internetausfälle und dann sitzt du da und dann nimmst du dann irgendwie so ein Alibi-Buch in die Hand und liest dann so ein paar Seiten und denkst dir, was mache ich denn eigentlich mit meinem Leben, was soll das denn? Soll ich jetzt mal rausgehen, mich mal irgendwie hinlegen? Was macht man aber draußen, wo geht man denn dann dahin? Ja, man ist so richtig beängstigt, als wäre der Boden unter den Füssen weggezogen. Und am Ende refresht man dann eh nur noch die ganze Zeit und dann irgendwann geht's wieder. Und dann spielt man die meiste Zeit den Dinosaurier bei Chrome. Ja, macht aber auch Spaß. Macht aber auch Spaß. Duckst du dich manchmal bei den Flugsauriern? Ich duck mich manchmal auch zu viel. Ja genau, man muss sich nicht immer ducken, aber ich duck mich trotzdem bei jedem Flugsaurier. Ich duck mich aber auch gerne. Ich find's geil, man fühlt sich, als hätte man Skill.
Als hätte man was gemacht.
Genau. Man fühlt sich, auch wenn es nicht nötig war, denkt man sich auch bei Flugsauern, die zu hoch fliegen.
Man duckt sich auch viel zu selten.
Ich hab was getan.
Wann hast du dich das letzte Mal im echten Leben geduckt?
Ich duck mich sehr viel.
Ach stimmt, du bist sehr gross.
Ich duck mich sehr viel, ja. Ich laufe oft in Äste rein, weil bei mir ist dann, ich bin zu gross, weil, also das kennen Leute, die ihr normale Größe habt, die kennen das nicht, aber man bei Wegen zum Beispiel, auf normalen Fußgängen, wegen Bordsteinen, Bürgersteigen, schneidet man Äste nur bis zu einer gewissen Höhe sauber ab, damit Leute langgehen können. Ich bin zu gross, ich laufe oft in Äste rein, die ein grosses Problem sind, weil ich ja immer auf mein Handy gucke, auf den Boden gucke und dann siehst du immer Äste nicht, die einfach in deinem Gesicht geschleudert werden. Und was machst du denn? Ist es dann so ein Also du gehst dann so geduckt, schleichend oder machst du den Limbo oder wie gehst du da? Es ist immer wieder neu, es ist ja keine Astwand die Decke ist ja kein Dickicht, sondern es sind Maläste, die kommen. Und immer wieder neu bin ich erstaunt und schreck davor zurück, weil ich ja nur diesen schwarzen Schatten dann irgendwann beim Augenwinkel sehe und dann denke ich mir, es wäre ein Tier und ducke mich schlagartig darunter hinweg. Aber kannst du das nicht so in deinen Gang mit einbauen, dass du dann, weil man geht ja manchmal im Gang so ein bisschen runter, kannst du das dann nicht so machen, dass du genau an den Stellen, wo du hast es, dass du dann so kurz in die Knie gehst, so ganz, ganz, so als wäre genau samlos. Ja, ja, meistens gehe ich dann aber rechts vorbei und links vorbei, aber das stimmt schon auch, man müsste eigentlich die ganze Zeit auf Knien gehen, leicht, wie beim Skifahren, wo man immer leicht in den Knien ist. Ich finde es auch wahnsinnig lustig, wie wenn man so einfach mal als normaler Mensch sich so einen Skiort anguckt, wo alle auf Skischuhen rumlaufen, das ist albern, ja. Das ist meine größte Angst, dass Aliens irgendwann irgendwo in, weiß ich nicht, so Kitzbühel landen und dann da einfach mal Ischgl und dann da stehen und so denken, what, so laufen die für dicke Schuhchen an. Ja, vor allem, man hat so diese flexiblen, perfekt von der Evolution vorgebenden Füsse und dann ballert man da einfach so ein Betonteil drum. Man geht bergauf, auf einer glatten Fläche mit diesen weirden, dicken, bunten, oft bunten, muss man sagen, Schuhen. Das sieht einfach absurd aus. Ich verbinde die größten und schlimmsten Tiefe meines Lebens mit diesen Skischuhen, weil wenn man mal ein gewisses Körpervolumen hat und übergewichtig ist, kann man mit Skischuhen teilweise wirklich echte Probleme haben, nicht mehr an seine Bindung ranzukommen, an seine Skibindung ranzukommen, weil du dich nicht so flexibel nach unten beugen kannst. Und für mich war das teilweise echt ein Problem. Und gerade wenn man dann jetzt nicht irgendwie Stöcke hat oder so, mit denen man die aufmachen kann und dann so Snowblades fährt, wie die coole junge Gesellschaft das macht und sich dann so runterbeugen muss, das war ganz unangenehm.
Du bist wie so eine Schildkröte aufgeschmissen einfach.
Du bist einfach komplett aufgeschmissen.
Du denkst dir so, ja, der sterbe ich jetzt nicht.
Du legst dich im Berg, wie an den Gotthard geschmettert.
Genau, du denkst dir so, wie lange dauert es, bis man erfriert?
Ja, 20 Minuten, 30 Minuten, weiss man nicht. Aber es soll dir, wie lange dauert es, bis man erfriert? Ja.
20 Minuten, 30 Minuten, weiß man nicht.
Aber es soll ein schöner Tod sein.
Es soll ein sehr schöner Tod sein, ja.
Echt? Ja?
Ja, weil du irgendwann wirst so warm, wohlig warm.
Ja?
Und dann merkst du es vorbei und ist aber auch egal.
Schöner Tod.
Ja? Würdest du gerne erfrieren, ist das der schönste Tod für dich?
So Titanic-mäßig, dann so in ganz eiskalten Wasser.
Oh, aber ertrinken ist, glaube ich, nicht schön.
Nee, du ertrinkst eher, ich glaube, du erfrierst eher, bevor du ertrinkst, oder? Na, wenn du die Schwimmweste an hast, kannst du ja nicht ertrinken. Oder? Nee, Stefan, ich bin mir nicht sicher. Schwimmweste an? Ja, Rettungsweste. Ja, stimmt. Ach so eine geile Lampe an, die schön leuchtet. Das kann auch sein, und eine schöne Pfeife, bei manchen noch eine Querflöte, eine Trommel oder so, dass man dann so ein bisschen Abwechslung hat. Eine ganze Band, ganz kleines Saxophon. Wie geil, wenn man irgendwann so in zehn Jahren so eine Nintendo Switch einfach aus dem Ärmel zieht. Oh, geil, schön bis hin Smashball. Ja, weil Leute erfahren, dass du nicht durchdrehst dann, wenn du noch Zelda spielen kannst. Ja, genau, man kann dann gegeneinander spielen. Man ist sofort in einem Netzwerk drin mit allen anderen Switches und kann dann ein bisschen daddeln.
Ja, alle die so verstreut im Meer rumtreiben.
Ja.
Und hast du so einen Salzstreuer recht?
Geil, yes, ich überlebe, schön erstmal ein bisschen Salz kübeln.
Ja, ein bisschen doof im Salzwasser.
Ja, gut, sorry.
Ja, okay, das stimmt.
Nee, war doof, Verrennt man sich manchmal. Werbung. Ganz ehrlich, ich liebe mein good old Taxi. Schön von A nach B kommen und gerade wenn du mal keine Zeit hast, kommst du einfach am Ziel an. Ja, aber da soll ich jetzt irgendein Taxi-Anruf-Service irgendwo auf Drichtlinien. Nein, gibt es natürlich auch als App. Gibt es natürlich auch als App. Was? Alles mittlerweile gibt es als App. My Taxi war es immer., mittlerweile heißt es Free Now. Und das Coole ist, mittlerweile kannst du sogar ein bisschen günstiger auch einfach einen Fahrrad zu dir bestellen. Das ist halt kein Taxi, das heißt Ride der Service. Es ist ein bisschen billiger und du kommst trotzdem genauso gut ans Ziel mit lizenzierten Fahrern. Und du weißt vorher, wie viel es kostet, die Fahrt. Ride gibt es bereits in einigen Großstädten Deutschlands, Hamburg, Berlin, Köln, Düsseldorf, München und Frankfurt. Und für alle, die Freen auch noch nicht nutzen, für die haben wir ein ganz kleines Schmankerl im Angebot. Denn ihr könnt den Vouchercode UFO7 benutzen. UFO und die Zahl 7 und dann kriegt ihr 7 Euro Rabatt. Viel Spaß, gute Fahrt. Bis dann, viel Spaß beim Podcast. Werbung. Wie unangenehm muss es für so einen Süsswasserfisch sein, im Salzwasser zu sein.
Also stell dir vor, du besuchst einen Kumpel, einen Cousin oder sowas, steigst aus dem ICE aus und in der Luft ist halt Salz, überall.
Und du hast Salz in den Augen, Salz im Mund und denkst dir, was ist denn hier los?
Und er so, hey, was sehen meine süßen, müden Augen?
Florentin, was ist denn hier los bei euch? Was ist das in der Luft? Hey, was wie in der Luft? Ist das Salz? Komm, lass dich mal drücken, hey! Ja, danke, freut mich, aber ist das hier Salz? Hey, na, altes Haus, lange nicht gesehen. Auf zur Hölle habt ihr Salz in der Luft? Hier ist alles normal, alles ist Salz. Zwischen Salzwasser, hey Hey, es ist Salz noch. Das ist erschrecklich. Ich sterbe. Woran? Ich sterbe trotzdem. Ach so, Osmose? Was? Deine letzten Worte waren Osmose. Osmose? Wenn du jetzt auf eine Schnecke Salz machst, soll man nicht, ja. Mein Gott, Stefan. Nichts darf man mehr sagen. Wenn du im Garten Schneckenplage hast und dann machst du Salz drauf, dann gehen die ein. Das sieht ganz, ganz furchtbar aus. Das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz, ganz schlimmer Tod. Genau, wie für die Fische. Genau, aber warum haben Salzwasser Fische nicht? Was ist denn anatomisch an der Haut bei denen anders? Ist es die Haut, die was anderes ist? Sind die Augen, die anders, was ist anders an Salzwasserfischen? Warum kann es nicht irgendwie sein, dass mal irgendwie was mit dem Landstrich wegbricht oder so und das ganze Salzwasser sich mit dem Süsswasser vermischt? Das ist die grosse Angst, glaube ich, der Salzwasser, oder? Wer hat mehr Angst eigentlich vor dem anderen Wasser? Aber Süsswasser sind doch Seen, oder? Ja, und Flüsschen. Und Salzwasser ist das Meer.
Flüsschen und Sechen. Flüsschen und Bächlein.
Sowas. Ja. Aber die Ozeane sind hauptsächlich Salz.
Nee, glaube ich, immer salzig.
Und dann das Süsswasser... Mittelmeer ist aber auch salzig,
aber ist auch eine Art See.
Und dann das... Streng genommen ist alles eine Art
See. Ja, aber dann das
süße, süße Wasser regnet
runter und fließt dann in den Ozean und wird dann salzig. Oder es fließt in den See und bleibt süss-süss. Süss-süss. Ja, aber wer hat denn mehr Angst vor dem anderen Wasser? Können die Süsswasserfische besser im Salzwasser überleben, als Salzwasserfische im Süsswasser überleben können? Ich glaube, Salz ohne Scheiß, ein bisschen vielleicht auch fieses jetzt zu postualisieren, aber ich glaube, dass Salzwasserfische die härteren Gesellen sind.
Wer in Salz lebt, schafft es auch im Süsswasser. Vielleicht liegt es an der Wortwahl, weil man hätte es ja nicht Süsswasser nennen müssen, man kann es ja auch Herbwasser nennen oder irgendwie, ja, salz ist süss ist schon so ein Gegensatz. Ja, aber wobei, das stimmt auch wahrscheinlich nicht, weil diese, in meiner Aquarium, aus meiner Aquariumphase, weiß ich nicht mehr viel.
Ich weiß nur, dass man, wenn man jetzt ein Salzwasser-Aquarium haben wollen würde, dann muss der Salzgehalt halt penibel genau abgestimmt werden. Also weil du ein bisschen zu viel Salz hast, sagen die Fische, was ist denn hier im Wasser? Und man denkt so, ja, die ganze Zeit Salz im Wasser. Ja, genau. Wow, jetzt habe ich den Salzsteuer ein bisschen zu lange drüber gehalten und jetzt fanden alle an zu sterben, weil es große Massenpanik oder was. Ja, und bei ein bisschen zu wenig Salz sagen alle Leute. Schmeckt so ein bisschen lasch irgendwie. Ja, so ein bisschen, ja, bräuchte noch ein bisschen Pepp einfach. Ich kann es nicht ausdrücken, aber ah, jetzt, ah, jetzt hat, ja, jetzt hat, jetzt haben wir es. Oh, aber jetzt ein bisschen, oh, jetzt ist ein bisschen direkt tot. Sofort tot. tot. Ja, und das ist doch dann auch, deswegen im Süsswasser gehen die bestimmt sofort vor die Hunde. Ja. Und wiederum anders, weil ich nicht, Süsswasserfische kurz sagen, weird as fuck, meine Augen brennen wie die Hölle, aber ich halte es hier aus. Aber das wäre dann mal eine RTL2-Show, die ich unterstützen würde. So wirklich Süsswasser gegen Salzwasser, der grosse Clash. Und dann wirft man die gegenseitig in die Gewässer, guckt, wer geht ein, wer nicht, macht so ein längster Fisch, grösster Fisch, das finde ich mal gut. Ja, herdester Fisch, schwächster Fisch. Schwerster Fisch. Ich glaube so Haie, sensible Tierchen. Ich glaube so, ja, tun immer, wir haben acht, neunzehn bis neunzehn Reihen Zähne, so, wir können dich kaputt beißen mit nur einem Happen. Aber ich glaube, sobald es da ins Süsswasser geht ... Ja, ich glaube, sobald die mal zu Hause sind ... Ich glaube, die werden auch sehr von Selbstzweifeln geplagt. Ja, ja, ich glaube, die sind auch innen drin. Es ist ein hartes Äusseres, aber weicher Kern. Ja, ganz herr. Ich glaube, so ganz weicher Kern, so sehr sensiblichen ... Viel Selbstzweifel. Selbstzweifel, Depression. Ja, hab jetzt wieder nichts gefangen. Muss ich so sein, warum bin ich so böse?
Die anderen Fische schwimmen immer weg von mir.
Ja, ich bin so böse, um was zu kompensieren eigentlich, um meinen schwachen Charakter zu kompensieren. Da ist auch viel Quatsch dabei, wobei die Delfine, die nach außen immer Friede voll Eierkuchen zeigen, innen drin glaube ich riesige Arschlöcher sind. Die sind auch, glaube ich, die einzigen Fische, äh, Fische, äh, Säugetiere, äh, ne, die einzigen Tiere sogar, wollte ich eigentlich sagen, die andere Tiere vergewaltigen.
Ah ja, aber dann ins Luftloch, ne, so richtig, so dass sie dann auch sterben.
Ne, ins Auge auch so.
Aber unter Wasser ist eh keine Luft, ne?
Ne. Warum das Ne, habe ich nicht verstanden, ne?
Ne?
Doch, ist ja, ab und zu. Wo, Die atmen ja auch was Sauerstoff ein, mit den Kiemen. Ne, ja mit dem Luftloch doch nicht. Ne, ne, damit nicht, damit pusten sie es raus. Ja, aber ist nicht die Idee eines Säugetiers, dass sie gerade keine Kiemen haben? Ach ja, genau, ne, Kiemen haben definitiv natürlich nicht. Die nehmen ja Luft durch, die atmen das ja ein und dann pusten sie es raus. Und dann müssen sie die ganze Zeit, die müssen die ganze Zeit die Luft anhalten. Und dann zwei Wochen. Nee. Die kommen ja über Wasser. Stündchen. Luft, ne? Weitere nicht. Wir wissen es einfach nicht. Flughunde, wurde mir gesagt, ist ganz gut, dass man die nicht domestiziert hat, weil die haben ein Loch für alles. Und das ist natürlich von der Menschheit nicht akzeptiert. Und ich glaube, oh scheiss, dass das wirklich ein Mitgrund ist. Menschen sind auch so ach, finde ich süss, komm, domestizieren wir. Moment, aber wie atmen und Ausscheidungen und alles durch ein Loch? Richtig, ja, ja. Und das ist dann der Mund, oder was? Ja. Wie? Die scheiden ihre Fäkalien mit dem Mund aus. Ja, ist scheiße. So, da kannst du jetzt mit deinem Evolution-Juche-Schild wieder einpacken, weil das ist einfach so kacke, das ist einfach so ein Tier, einfach so geil, du bist ein Hund, cool, geil, relativ oben in der Nahrungskette, cool, süss, irgendwie auch flink und so, kannst was machen, kannst dich bewegen, bist dich lahmarschig, hast auch ein okayes Gehirn und fliegen kannst du auch, mega, geil, mega, wo ist der Haken, ja alles kommt aus einem Loch raus, ja, nee, dann hätte ich gerne lieber die Flügel nicht, so, dann mach mich zum Hund und dann mach mich nochmal, nee, nee, nee, du kriegst schon auch das, Flügel kriegst du, aber dafür ein Loch. Ciao, ciao, Tür. Wir haben jetzt noch Flughund und Regenwurm. Ciao. Ciao. Ja, das ist total bescheuert. Deswegen glaube ich, der Mensch ist ja dann auch knallhart so, ne? Der sagt dann, das finde ich cool, das Tier, süss, hätte ich gern in drei Farben und in achtzehn Rassen.
Aber du brauchst ja, finde ich, eine klare Hierarchie der Tiere, damit Buddhismus Sinn ergibt. Damit du sagen kannst, okay, es gibt manche Tiere, die objektiv schlechter sind als andere, damit du dich da, damit du Reinkarnation, wenn du gut gemacht hast, wirst du ja besser reinkarniert oder schlechter reinkarniert. Diese Rangliste hätte ich gerne mal. Diese Rangliste, wo jemand mal alle Tiere aufgeschrieben hat. Du musst doch mal irgendein Buddhist.
Aber ist das eine Gut- bis Schlecht-Rangliste?
Ja, klar.
Eine Nett- bis Bö. Diese Rangliste, wo jemand mal alle Tiere aufgeschrieben hat. Muss doch mal irgendein Buddhist.
Aber ist das eine Gut- bis Schlecht-Rangliste?
Ja, klar.
Eine nett- bis böse Rangliste?
Nee, auf der anderen Seite, ich glaube, so Hardcore-Buddisten, die machen dann auch keine Käfer kaputt und so, weil sie ja denken, ah, okay, der gibt sein Bestes, der will halt wieder hoch reinkarniert werden, wäre fies.
Obwohl, auf der anderen Seite, wenn er ihn töten würde, dann würde er wahrscheinlich eher hoch reinkarniert werden als runter, weil er selber einen schlechten Menschen kaputt gemacht hat. Das ist kompliziert. Das ist die grössere Sünde, dieses Arschloch zu zerquetschen, weil es war ja auch ein Arschloch, es wäre ja nicht ein Käfer. Die Frage ist, hilft man ihm nicht? Weil wenn der Käfer, weil der wird ja wahrscheinlich so okay laufen, und wenn du ihn totmachst, dann ist er die Chance, dass er als was Besseres reinkarniert. Also du verteilst eher ein Segen, indem du hässliche Kacktiere, die weiter unten stehen, totmachst. Aber auf der anderen Seite geht es ja von deinem eigenen Karma-Konto ab. Also eigentlich ist er das Selbstlose, sein eigenes Karma zu opfern, um den anderen zu helfen, höher zu reinkarnieren, was wieder moralisch wäre, was ihn wieder... Guck mal jetzt auf dein Handy, ich glaube, das ist jetzt eine Push-Mitteilung von Buddha, der sagt, ja, stopp, wir müssen die Folge jetzt löschen. Tatsächlich, der Alarme, hör auf mit dem Quatsch. Stop it, stop it. Wir müssen die Folge löschen, stop it, stop it, stop it. Stop it. Farid, stop it, stop it. Wo, bitte, ist die nächste Staffel The Next Uri Geller. Ich vermisse diese Serie so sehr. Germany's Next Topmodel, achte, zehnte Staffel mittlerweile. Bachelor, milliardeste Staffel, interessiert mich kein bisschen. Das war das beste Trash-TV für mich, war The Next Uri Geller. Ich glaube, da sind einfach eine Menge Kinder gestorben. Kinder? Ja, die das angeschaut haben und dann entweder mit dieser Nailgun oder mit irgendwelchen Löffeln und einfach raufgegangen sind. War Nailgun Stop It, Farid? Ich glaube, das war die Nailgun, ja. Stop It. Aber das war, ehrlich gesagt, das war die so beste Show aller Zeiten. Ich fand daran alles toll. Ich fand Uri Geller auch ein super Menschen dafür. Also die beste Portion Weirdness, die hat sich wahnsinnig ernst genommen. Das nervt mich ja auch, dass die meisten Shows mittlerweile schon selber ihre Ironieebene mitliefern, was mich ja als lustigen Twitterer dann, wenn ich dann so eine Show gucke und da mitschreiben will und so, auch nervt. Und deswegen, ich will ja die Ironie dann mal reinbringen als Twitterer. Kriegen wir Uri Geller in den Podcast als Gast? Ist das eine Möglichkeit für Folge 300 oder so? Oder was ist seine Lieblingszahl? Vielleicht 211. Steim oder Schalosch? Weiß ich nicht. 211 vielleicht. Vielleicht ist 211 seine Lieblingszahl und dann kriegen wir in der Folge 211 gleich den Podcast. Das wäre ein schönes Uriella. Was macht der eigentlich jetzt? Ich weiß es nicht. Und wer war der nächste Urigella? Macht der Werbung irgendwie für Hagebau oder was? Und wo ist der nächste Urigella? Wer war es? Gab es nicht zwei Staffeln? Gorax, glaube ich. Vincent Raven. Gorax. Das ist nicht mehr genau. Aber es ist eine tolle Welt. Es ist eine tolle Welt. Ja, tolle Welt einfach. Diese Zaubererwelt. Vor allem, ich glaube, es ist schwer, wenn du als Zauberer anfängst. Du musst dir überlegen, welche Art von Zauberer werde ich. Wäre ich so ein Penn & Teller, cooler, sympathischer Typ oder werde ich so ein Vincent Raven-Weirdo? Und ich glaube, man muss auch aufpassen, dass man nicht in die falschen Kreise gerät. Es ist, glaube ich, ein Seiltanzakt, ja. Es ist ein Seiltanzakt, du kannst in beide Richtungen abdriften. Und ich glaube, sobald du deinen Eltern sagst, Mama, Papa, ich bin Magier, hoffen die auch so, da gibt es auch bestimmt Kreise, die dich aufnehmen und so.
Ich glaube, da gibt es auch für Eltern auch so Beratungsgespräche, die dann auch das lernen, wie man damit umgeht und so.
Und dann, glaube ich, ist auch der erste Tipp, passt auf, dass euer Sohn in die richtigen Kreise kommt.
Halt den von grossen Menschen-Sphären, wo Krähen rumfliegen und schwarze Hunde. Und Gewitter ist den ganzen Tag. Und den ganzen Tag Gewitter ist. Und erstes Alarmzeichen, langer Ledermantel und lange Haare. Ich glaube, du bist ein Zauberer, hast du deine ersten paar Gigs, bist du erfolgreich, aber irgendwann sitzt du mal Backstage und fragst deinen Kollegen so, und wie bist du zum Zauber gekommen? Ja, der Erzengel Ishmael hat mir die meine Kräftige und denkst dir, nein, ich bin irgendwo falsch abgewogen, fuck, wie komme ich hier wieder raus? Und du hast einen Kartentrick irgendwie, wo dann so eine Rubik's Cube oder eine Kugel gelöst wird und wenn der andere irgendwie dann versucht, Geister anzurufen, dann denkst du, was ist das für eine Show überhaupt? Was ist das für eine Kackshow? Ja, es gibt zwei Arten. Die einen, die leben das, und die anderen, die gehen halt cool damit um, dass sie Tricks beherrschen. Ja. Und die, die das leben, ist immer schwierig. Seine ist Teil des Acts irgendwie. Und was einem auffällt auch immer, ist, dass die Kinderpornografie-Dichte, Kinderpornographie-Täter-Dichte bei Magiern extrem hoch ist. Ja, wirklich? Gibt es da Studien? Ich weiß nicht, aber es ist so furchtbar und gruselig. Aber es ist doch schon wieder jetzt auch einer, der Jan Ruven, meine ich, der dabei war, auch bei The Next Uri Geller. Echt? Ja, und das ist ganz, ganz schlimm. Ich glaube, das muss mal jemand untersuchen. Die Schnittmenge zwischen China-Pornografie-Tätern und Magiern ist extrem hoch. Vor allem haben die dann wieder eine Überschneidung zwischen Christen und Magiern durch Pädophilie, was denen wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht gefällt. Weil die sind ja Gegner, die einen sind ja die Diener des Teufels und die einen sind die Diener des Gottes. Und wenn die sich dann treffen wiederum durch dieses gemeinsame Hobby, glaube ich, kann es zu ganz, ganz schwierigen Situationen kommen. Oder man kann so Brücken schlagen. Oder man kann... Das ist natürlich eine schöne Geste. Ich weißiss noch nicht wie, aber vielleicht auch nicht.
Aber es kann eine Versöhnung sein, das stimmt schon.
Kann schon eine Versöhnung sein.
Aber ist nicht jetzt der Papst auch krank eigentlich?
Coronavirus, ja.
Das wäre ganz ungünstig.
Ja, ein Stück weit ein Gewinn für alle Nichtgläubigen.
Also es wäre ja albern.
Oder er besiegt die Krankheit und sagt, okay, Gott hat mich gerettet.
Aber Gott hat dich auch krank gemacht.
Ja.
Komm, komm.
Ja gut, okay.
Immer diese Pressekonferenzen im Vatikan.
Immer so vielen Dank, dass Gott diese Helfer für die große Überschwemmung gesendet hat.
Ja, aber er hat ja auch überschwemmt die Welt.
Ja, komm.
Alle Lachen, Gelächter, Abspann. Diese Serie wird immer weirder. Ich weiß nicht, Staffel 10. Ja, das stimmt schon. Wie machen die das eigentlich? Wie biegen sich das wieder zurecht, die lustigen Kirchenonkels? Uiuiuiui, da bist du jetzt aber ein bisschen edgy hier. Das ist richtig ed nicht wie es sich zurechtbiegen ist nicht so einfach ganz schwierig ganz einfach gott ist kein einfaches thema ne vor allem von mir hat zwei theologen als eltern auch dann teilweise und dann hat sie einfach bei ihr in der wohnung da manchmal so kerzen mit Kre Kreuzen drauf und so und die ist halt gar nicht gläubig und lebt auch ein ganz normales Leben wie du und ich, aber ab und zu stehen halt so Osterkerzen mit so grossen Zahlen und Kreuzen sind dann einfach in der Wohnung rum und so ein paar, ich finde auch nichts spannendes als Wohnungen vom Pfarrer, so wo alles, also das fand ich immer spannend, einmal habe ich einen Pfarrer damals interviewt für meine Hausarbeit über Dan Browns Sakrileg und da war ich dann bei der. Und er hat dich rausgejagt wegen diesem Teufelszeug. Ja genau, er hat mich rausgejagt mit Weihrauch und so Weihwasser hat er mich rausgespustet und es ist dann mit der Haut geätzt, ganz toll. Und das fand ich immer sehr spannend, diese Wohnung zu sehen, viel aus Holz, viel so, es war auch noch Weihrauch, so ein bisschen bin ich ganz ehrlich, wo man dann sagt, Weihrauch bitte nicht in der, bin ich in der Wohnung. Ja, aber gut, jeder weiß, dass das eines der Praxis ist, Pfarrer zu werden. Ja, nee, war schön. Warst du schon mal in einer Wohnung von Pfarrer? Ja, doch, absolut ein guter Freund von mir ist Pfarrer. Pfarrer so ein, aber evangelisch, glaube ich. Da ist das alles so ein bisschen. Ja, ach Gott. So ein bisschen. Die sind ja die Punks der Religion. Aber die hatten auch so eine krasse Missionierungsgeschichte. Also die waren dann irgendwo in Südamerika im Urwald, in Anführungszeichen, unterwegs und haben da so Missionierungsgeschichten gemacht und und aber also den Leuten da geholfen und so, aber war immer so ein bisschen weird. War weird? Aber, ne, ich weiß es nicht, ich hatte da nie einen großen Besuch davon. Vor allem die großen, diese Totenköpfe im Haus aus dem Amazonas waren vielleicht weird. Ja, es war ein bisschen gruselig schon. Und dann diese Pfeilgiftrohre, die dann da rumstanden vielleicht. Ja, ein bisschen gruselig. Ja, es war furchtbar. Das war ein bisschen schon mehr kürzend. Hast du mal so Ziele auf der Welt, wo du eigentlich mal hin möchtest, so wie Südamerika oder sowas? Nee. Nee, gar nicht? Willst du die Welt sehen? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Will Florentin die Welt sehen? Überhaupt nicht. Nein? Nee, gar nicht. Gar nicht. Also wenn jetzt Sat.1 kommen würde und sagen, okay, Florentin reist um die Welt, nee. Ja. Nee, klar, Geoguesser, irgendwie Google Maps maps mal irgendwie den den globus drehen gerne aber so extra vorbeischauen hast du gar keinen bock auf reisen eigentlich ne momentan nicht vielleicht kommt das noch nie momentan ist noch nie bock auf reisen also ich hätte schon so bock auf new york noch mal oder so oder amerika und auch mal da irgendwie vielleicht in eine andere gegend irgendwie dann so texas steppe oder so kleinen städte milwaukee oder so würde mich mal interessieren, was man halt so aus der Popkultur kennt, wo es dann halt so die Mall gibt und die Vorschule, aber alles halt so ein bisschen schäbig und uberflächlich, aber würde mich auch mal interessieren, aber ansonsten nicht unbedingt. Also Japan, Asien, Marokko, ja, Tansania, Ruanda, Uganda, Namibia, würde ich natürlich alle, nee, tatsächlich nicht, ich bin glaube ich sehr, sehr Nesthockerisch.
Du bist in deinem Kopf zu Hause, glaube ich.
Gut, aber warum, ist nicht unbedingt schlecht.
Nee, was, das war gar nicht echt gemeint. Ja.
Nee, du schaffst dir die Welt um dich herum in deinem Köpfchen.
Ja.
Und da hilft die Verletzung dann nicht. Da ist die Verlichung fast eine Beleidigung. Köpfchen, ja. Köpfli. In deinem Köpfli. Ach ja, ich würde gerne mal reisen, mal wieder. Ich freue mich auch, wenn dann mal beruflich so eine Pause ist, dass man mal vielleicht ein bisschen die Welt sich anguckt. Schon unterwegs? Ist das schon ein Ziel? Ich würde gerne mit dem Segelboot die Weltmeere die Weltmeere einmal bereisen, von überall hin. Einmal mit dem Segelboot die Welt umkreisen, finde ich schön. Weiß ich nicht, ob das einigermaßen realistisch ist. Hat man dann immer so einen Skipper dabei eigentlich, oder muss man das selber wirklich dann lernen? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Und dann ist er dann immer dabei dabei oder was? Ich weiß gar nicht, was ein Skipper ist. Ist das auch ein Delfin? Kapitän. Ein Kapitän, achso. Kapitän, okay. Ist er dann dabei immer? Das war vielleicht die dümmste Frage, die ich gestellt habe. Kann sein. Nee, weil sich Skipper auf Flipper reimt, das war gerade dein Gedanke. Achso, ja, das kann auch sein. Deswegen hast du gedacht, Fisch. Das kann auch sein. Ich glaube, was ich gerne machen würde, wäre irgendwie so eine Suche, so eine Abenteuersuche, so zu sagen, okay, ich will was suchen. Ah, den Stein der Weisen. Genau, irgendwie eine verlorene Ruine oder so was, so eine Ausgrabung, glaube ich, so Abu Simbel. Das fände ich mal cool. Gibt es da eigentlich mal so eine KarteListe der ungelösten mathematischen Rätsel, wo jeder Dulli sich auch mal hinsetzen kann zu Hause und überlegen kann, was ist denn da denn eigentlich, die Primzahl Wiederholungen von Pi herauszufinden. Hat jemand sich schon mal die Mühe gemacht und jede einzelne Zahl von 1 bis 100 da eingereicht als Antwort, einfach um zufällig vielleicht das richtige Ergebnis zu treffen? Ja. Tatsächlich, so 38. Kommt hin. Nicht schlecht. Das Rechner sagt, nicht mehr Error. Genau, da gibt es sich das mit ungefundenen Schätzen, von dem man aber weiß, dass sie existieren. Nee, das war eine Frage, müsste man mal haben. Bestimmt, also natürlich Bernsteinzimmer ganz oben, aber ich glaube auch noch viel. Aber Bernsteinzimmer ist auch noch ein bisschen so eine Legende, oder? Nee, das gab es ja, schon wirklich, aber das ist halt dann irgendwann, wegen dem Krieg musste das verladen werden, in Kisten, und niemand weiß, wo das nirgendwo wieder aufgetaucht. Niemand weiß, wo das passiert ist. Das gibt es wirklich. Das gibt es, ja klar. Und da gibt es auch Fotos von auch? Ja, ja klar. Und da gibt es auch, wird auch rekonstruiert und so, irgendwie kann ja Russland oder Prag oder Polen oder sowas. Da weiß ich nichts drüber, wirklich gar nichts. Lies mal durch, ist ein schöner Wikipedia-Artikel und man weiß auf jeden Fall, aber Bernstein ist leider auch relativ leicht entflammbar, also vielleicht ist es verbrannt irgendwann. Ist da wirklich ein Bernsteinzimmer?
Ja, das ist halt so eine komplette Verkleidung.
Also halt so dann irgendwie die Möbel, glaube ich,
und halt so die Wände und so, alles aus Bernsteinzimmer. Auch eigentlich so wertvoll, ne? Super krass.
Ich glaube, Bernstein sich ist nicht so wertvoll,
aber da geht es halt dann mehr um die Kunstfertigkeit.
Ist Versteigerndes Harz, richtig? Bernstein ist Versteigerndes Harz.
Sowas, ja. Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein grosses Ding.
Ich glaube, auch so Görings Kunstschatz und so,
diese ganzen Raubkunst und sowas, da ist glaube ich auch viel verschollen, wo man auch mal bestimmt viel noch in Kellern rumsteht. Aber Deutschland ist doch wahnsinnig dicht besiedelt. Das ist alles nicht in Deutschland dann, ne? Wahrscheinlich schon. Ich glaube schon, so Plünderungen vom Ober Salzberg und so, glaube ich, da kann schon noch viel rumliegen. Da liegen irgendwie so Monets und Picassos dann irgendwo im Keller rum. Irgendwo im Keller. Ja, irgendwo im Keller. Und da kommst du ja nicht ran, wenn es da hinter so einer Tischtennisplatte steht. Ach so, hier haben wir so ein Indiana-Jones-artiges Abenteuer vorgestellt, wo ich irgendwie nach Marokko fliegen kann. Ja, genau, aber jetzt, ich meine nur, das... Ich will jetzt nicht nach Garmisch-Badenkirchen fahren, um da irgendwie bei Herrn Meierlingen zu... Um da mal zu klingeln, wir müssen mal in ihren Keller. Ja. Aber vielleicht klappt es ja. Das ist aber nicht das Abenteuer, was mich vorgestellt hat. Ja, aber stell dir vor, du findest da irgendwie dann Van Gogh oder so. Wie krass das wäre. Mir geht es ja nicht um das Ziel, sondern um die Reise. Oder, was mich auch interessieren würde, es gibt, glaube ich, zwei oder drei Theaterstücke von Shakespeare, die verschollen sind. Und man weiss, dass es die gab, die sind irgendwo aufgetaucht in irgendeiner Folioio-Liste oder so. Und die sind einfach weg. Schau mal vor, du findest das und alle zeigen dann plötzlich auf Joanne K. Rowling, weil sie einfach die abgeschrieben hat. Genau, also so eins zu eins. Und aber so ein paar Namen geändert hat und es so eins zu eins Harry Potter. Ja. Und sie so, mhm, ja, das hat meine ... Oder halt so wirklich so eins zu eins. Meine Uroma hat mir das ... So eins zu eins Harry Potter und sie so ja das hat meine oder halt so wirklich so eins zu eins so eins zu eins die Lyrics von Angel oder sowas und alle so Robbie Williams so was soll das also so ein verscholltes so nett von Shakespeare, das fände ich auch mal cool, aber es ist natürlich schwer wo man anfängt zu suchen, weil dann das ist dann irgendwie vielleicht in England oder so, in England anfangen, vielleicht in so alten Archiven durchstöbern, aber ich meine, da gibt es ja genug Leute. In alten Archiven willst du ja nicht anfangen, das ist das ja nicht, schau mal. Ja gut, aber es gibt ja auch Archive, wo noch nicht alles gesichtet wurde, so wo man einfach sagt, ja, oder in so alten Beständen kann man das, oh, so doll eingeatmet. Eine Mücke mit ganz hoher Geschwindigkeit direkt in Stephans Mund geflogen. Kann man das ... Ich habe einen Kratzen im Hals in ein paar Tagen. Labello. Kann man das ... Kann man das noch machen, so als Ferienjob in so Archiven? Klar, natürlich. Gerade so Institut für Zeitgeschichte und so, wenn du sagst, so kann ich da nochmal hier so Marschbefehle von der Wehrmacht anschauen oder so? Ich hätte gerne einen Job, wo man in ein Archiv muss. Vielleicht Archivar. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee Ich glaube, er lehrt, aber ich kann auch... Nee, aber man kann auch Archäologie lernen. Oder alte Geschichte. Genau, aber der muss auch mal ins Archiv und dann mal gucken, wo denn Abusimbel der Tempel... Ich hätte auch Bock auf Archiv, aber ich glaube, du kannst relativ einfach in Archive gehen. Also das ist halt kein krasses Vatikan-Archiv oder so. Vielleicht ist da Shakespeare oder so, wurde es damals konfisziert von der Kirche, weil es irgendwie zu schlüpfrig war. Und dann irgendwie ist da die Urschrift, Transcript drin oder so. Ja, das finde ich auch nicht spannend. Das ist ja auch viel kaputt gegangen, so bei Bomba de Mons. Wollen wir nicht mal als Podcastufer mal so ein Abenteuer starten? Total gerne. Also ich hätte auch mal Bock auf Podcast-Ufer on the road. Ich kann mir das super vorstellen, dass wir zum Beispiel mal immer mal wieder einmal im Monat eine On-the-Road-Folge einstreuen. Du meinst damit einfach, dass wir im Auto sind? Nein, wo wir uns dokumentarisch um ein Rätsel, was wir uns aussuchen, vorher kümmern und es lösen. Und das sind dann einfach dokumentarische Folgen, die unsere Reise begleiten, auf der Suche nach Görings Kunstschatz. Was könnten wir realistischerweise finden? Görings Kunstschatz. Görings Kunstschatz, ja. Es ist glaube ich keine spannende Reise, aber ist ja egal, der Weg ist ja das Ziel, aber ähm... Du, wir können gerne nach Berchtesgaden fahren. Es ist glaube ich keine spannende Reise, aber der Weg ist ja das Ziel. Nee, das ist, glaube ich, keine spannende Reise, aber das Elemente wäre mega. Nee, das Ziel wäre das Ziel. Das Ziel wäre halt schon das Ziel, ja. Nee, bei uns wäre das Ziel das Ziel. Und wir würden ja die Reise zu unserem eigenen Ding machen, und das wäre ja auch lustig. Aber das finde ich zum Beispiel spannend, wenn wir mal irgendwann jetzt, wenn die Live-Shows dann wieder vorbei sind erstmal, dass wir dann vielleicht so dokumentarisch mal werden, kurz mal einmal im Monat vielleicht eine Documentary-Pufo-Folge machen, wo wir etwas suchen. Ich meine, was mir natürlich, was glaube ich das einfachste wäre, ist, wenn wir so Metalldetektoren mässig mal durch so einen Wald ziehen und mal gucken, was wir finden. Das schaue ich mir nämlich immer gerne auf YouTube an. Da gibt es so Treasure-Finder und das macht ja richtig Spaß, weil ich war ja in Verdun auf dem Schlachtfeld vom Ersten Weltkrieg und da haben wir ja auch Sachen gesucht und haufenweise gefunden. Alte Metallsplitter, Granaten, Hufeisen, Stein. Das ist da, wo du die Hand verloren hast, ne? Ja, gut, anderes Thema. Aber das hat richtig Spaß gemacht und man kann da echt noch mega viel finden. Wir haben eine Flasche im Wald gefunden, eine alte Flasche von 1916.
Ja, oder von 2009. Nee, nee, nee, an der Form hat man ganz klar erkannt, dass es eine alte Flasche war. Ja, oder von 2009. Ja, aber es hat auf jeden Fall richtig Spaß gemacht. Und da nochmal, wenn es da offene Fragen gibt, so irgendwie irgendwo eine napoleonische Schlacht, wo man nicht weiß, wo die war und da einfach mal danach suchen. Das fände ich auch cool. Fände ich auch mega. Aber falls ihr irgendwie ein Rätsel habt und sagt, es gibt da irgendwas, was ich noch finden muss.
Es gibt da draußen etwas, was ich wissen muss. Genau, so kleine Rätsel. Aber jetzt nicht so eine Schnitzeljagd oder so, dass ihr uns so ein Parcours macht. Nee, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich habe euch doch mal und dir auch The Mystery Show empfohlen. Ja. Toll. Es gibt nur sechs Folgen. Es gibt nur sehr wenige Folgen ich glaube, das könnten wir versuchen, vielleicht mal zu machen, wir können mal so Rätsel lösen. Vielleicht mal, wenn die Live-Shows vorbei sind, einmal im Monat machen wir eine Documentary-Folgen, wo wir mal Rätsel lösen, wenn nicht so schlecht. Wo wir da mal ein bisschen so einen coolen journalistischen Beitrag, so ein Investigativ. Wir machen uns auf die Suche. Hier stehen wir heute. Bei Frau Hunderding. Ja, dann haben wir so Interviewgäste und suchen im Wald. Fände ich richtig cool. Wir brauchen, glaube ich, nur den richtigen Fall. Also, falls ihr auch so Detektivarbeiten braucht oder irgendwie sowas. Schreibt uns. Wenn es so Crime ist, finde ich auch spannend. Ist vor allem auch für unsere Publicity gut, wenn wir da irgendwie so einen Fall lösen und so, weil wir in die Bild kommen oder in die Süddeutsche. Das wäre richtig gut. So einen alten Fall. So einen alten, kalten Fall. Ja, so einen cold, so einen arschkalten Fall. Ein eiskalter. Oder so ein Mord aus dem 17. Jahrhundert, wo alle sagen, ja scheiß drauf, scheiß drauf. Nee, wir klären den auf. Das war irgendwie Roger Mortimer. Und kein Nachfahr hat mehr irgendwie Bock darauf, zu wissen, was da los war. Und wir, nee, und nehmen den auch in den Arm und sagen, ja, ist alles gut, alles gut. Weißt du, worauf ich Bock habe? Dachboden. Was? Dachboden. Dachboden, Absuch. Auch so einen richtig alten Dachboden mit ganz viel Staub, mit alten Kisten. Und dann mal so, doch noch so alte Akten. Warum hast du Bock auf Archive, aber nicht auf den Dachboden? Ja, weil, das sag ich dir, weil Decken niedrig sind für mich. Ja, aber du robbst doch da eh. Und ist da so ein Wespennest und dann haben wir kein Abenteuer. Wespennest, es klingt erstens nach Hausstauballergie, Kicked-in. Abenteuer, das klingt nach, ja, okay. Du bist der schlechteste Abenteuer der Welt. Das klingt nach Wespennest. Och, meine alte Gruft, das klingt nach Staub, das klingt nach wandelnden Untoten. Nee, das klingt vor allem nach ewig wandern durch Wüste, so heiß, ölig rum, schwitze ich mir Arsch ab. Ja gut, dann bleibst du zu Hause. Ich bin hier. Du machst Social Media. Ja genau. Du postest unsere Fotos währenddessen. Ja, aber wenn ihr so recherchiert, was ich online googeln kann, wenn ihr mal eine Frage habt, kann ich mich anrufen. Geht's ins Archiv. Ich brauche, irgend so ein irgendwas, wo so Menschen verschwunden sind und niemand weiss, warum. Aber da wird es noch schnell problematisch, glaube ich, weil dann fangen wir da so an, so Selbstjustiz zu... Nee, wir wollen das nur, wir verfremden die Namen. Ich finde geil, einen Schatz zu finden. Ja, finde ich auch. Görings Kunstschatz. Du kommst immer wieder zu Göring, dann müssen wir halt nach Beresgaden. Ich sehe meine neue Wohnung, sehe die leeren Wände, sehe Platz für Görings Kunstschatz. Ja, das ist so eine jüdische Raubkunst, das wäre jetzt genau das richtig. Das passt da hin, ich habe schon ein Band im Blick. Du am Esszimmertisch. Oh ja, ein guter Ort für den ein oder andere jüdische Raubkunst. Du, das könnte ich arrangieren, da habe ichakte. Lass es da hinfahren, das können wir machen. Oder halt irgendwie nach Ägypten in die Wüste.
Hast du nicht erzählt, dass bei dir da unten in der Ecke, da kamen ja auch so ein paar schwierige Kameraden her aus der SS-Zeit?
Welche Ecke meinst du jetzt?
Bei dir aus der Ecke da unten, wo du herkommst, aus Süddeutschland.
Ja, da kam ja so ein paar schwierige Menschen kamen da ja her. Zum Beispiel da Herr Göring. Oder nicht? Ich weiß nicht, ob der aus Süddeutschland kam, aber ich kann... Hast du sie mal erzählt, dass einer von denen, dass bei dir da unten in den Kellern ab und zu mal Bilder gefunden werden auch? Häufiger mal auftauchen? Nee, jetzt glaube ich verwechselst du was. Ich weiss nur, dass in Berthesgaden, wo ich ab und zu war, weil meine Oma da gelebt hat. Das ist für mich genau da, wo du herkommst, aber in welcher Zeit weiß ich auch nicht genau. Nee, aber es ist noch ein bisschen tieferes Bayern sozusagen. Dass da der Obersalzberg war, wo ja Hitler immer im Sommer war und so und wo auch ganz viele Kunst und so was. Und da wurde, als die Amerikaner kamen, hat Göring nochmal seine ganzen Kunstschätze verladen auf so einen Zug und wollte damit fliehen und dass sie irgendwie in Sicherheit gebracht werden. Und das hat nicht mehr funktioniert. Da kamen schon die Amerikaner zu früh und dann wurde es beschlagnahmt. Aber es kann auch gut sein, dass da viel geplündert wurde von der ansässigen Bevölkerung, weil die sind dann alle abgehauen und dann war eben dieser ganze Obersalzberg offen und man konnte da plündern, wie man wollte und da gab es ja ganz krasse Weine und Kunstwerke und wahnsinnig teures Inventar und so und dann wurde das alles geplündert. und ich glaube, da wurde aber auch noch gekämpft, glaube ich, ich weiss es nicht mehr, 100% ich.
Aber eher so lustlos am Rande.
Ja, also ich weiss es nur aus Band of Brothers, weil die haben das sogar nach der Kapitulation noch, mussten die da noch irgendwie so versprengte Einheiten aus dem Ober-Salzberg bekämpfen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das wahr ist oder ob die Timeline anders ist, aber früher oder später waren da auf jeden Fall alle weg und dann konnte man da plündern. Und da kann es gut sein, dass auch viel von dem Kunstschatz irgendwie dann geplündert wurde.
Also geht es für uns nach Berchtesgaden und dann würden wir da mal gucken.
Ja, was sollen wir da machen? Wir können da natürlich an... Wir klingeln, hier und da, ja, na ja, wir werden nicht die Ersten sein auf dieser heißen Spur,
aber die Bevölkerung versteckt doch da was, offensichtlich in den Kellern.
Aber meinst du nicht, da wird es zu schnell zu ernst mit dem Nazi-Erben und so? Ja, das ist mir auch ein ernstes Anliegen. Ich dachte, du willst da so ein Lian-Abenteuer, da über so einen Krokodil verseuchten Fluss nicht zu hangeln. Du willst den Kristallschädel finden. Du willst nicht den Opfern des Zweiten Weltkrieges die Raubkunst, ja, wir sind vielleicht nicht der richtige Podcast, das hinzukriegen und auch richtig einzuordnen. Wir überlegen uns was. Wir geben uns nochmal in die Redaktion zurück, wir überlegen nochmal in unser Hauptquartier. Wobei ich weiß auch nicht, was das bringen soll, in mich gehen. Das ist vielleicht auch nicht gut. Vielleicht soll ich nicht gut. Nee, das bringt oft was. Vielleicht soll ich nicht in mich gehen, sondern andere fern vielleicht bessere Löwen. Nee, wir gehen nochmal in unser Hauptquartier, in unser HQ Baumhaus und versuchen dann nochmal alle Spuren zu ordnen. Aber falls ihr sagt, ihr habt so ein knackiges Ein-Wochenende-Abenteuer, was irgendwie in einem geilen Klima liegt, wo ich nicht mit meinen Allergien Probleme habe. Ja, wo man gut anreisen kann. Ja, ja, gut hinfliegen kann oder irgendwie ohne Stops oder so, schnell hin kann mit dem Zug oder so, keine Ahnung, einfach mal schnell. Und dann einfach mal irgendwie so eine knackige Schlagzeile, Mörder gefasst, Schatz gefunden, so. Gutes Frühstück, ab nach Hause. Und dann aber Sonntagmorgen auch wieder abreisen. Ja, dass ich Montag wieder hier sein kann, das wäre mir wichtig, wenn ich jetzt Montag wieder in Köln bin. Perfekt, das ist das richtige
Abenteuer. Falls ihr was habt, schreibt uns ansonsten,
haut rein. Und eine schöne Woche.
Wir haben letztes Mal in Berlin vergessen,
abzuheben. Wir sind nicht gut darin, naja.
Deswegen jetzt der offizielle Abheben.
Macht's gut. Tschüss, bis dann.